this is a fox news alert iran has fired
multiple missiles toward the u.s
consulate in irbil iraq a senior u.s
official tells fox none of the missiles
hit the consulate our own jennifer
griffin is reporting that there are
americans assigned to erbil who live and
work near the consulate including
military personnel now there are no
injuries that have been reported your
reaction to this breaking news is former
cia station chief and fox news
contributor dan hoffman dan we're still
getting more information on this
what can you tell us about this and what
does this mean for the u.s
well this has been a regular tactic that
iran has employed against the u.s
presence in iraq uh frankly for decades
you know this is uh iran wants the
remaining uh u.s military presence in
iraq to leave
they're trying to induce the the
government of iraq to do that even
though the united states has shifted to
an advisory role uh iran is also trying
to deliver a message to us uh regionally
uh just last week the israelis
reportedly struck a couple of uh irgc uh
generals are officers in uh in damascus
syria iran may be trying to exact
revenge uh on that target as well and uh
hardliners in iran are you know seeking
leverage against us as we negotiate what
to me looks like a pretty bad deal a
jcpoa
nuclear deal that looks a lot uh like
the first one which was very flawed yeah
then my second question is why strike
now is it because of the position of the
united states we know what china's doing
we know what russia is obviously doing
attacking ukraine it just seems like our
enemies now are all
acting all at once
or positioning themselves to act
yeah well it's that's been a pretty
continuous uh strategy that that iran
has deployed against us so i'm not so
sure that the timing is necessarily uh
you know a huge factor here remember you
know north korea is launching uh
ballistic missile tests right now that's
a concern the terrorists are gathering
strength and ungoverned space in
afghanistan
obviously we've got russia's unprovoked
barbaric invasion of of ukraine and
china threatening taiwan and ripping us
off in the united states so there's a
lot of threats out there i'll tell you
when i was at the cia
uh when michael morell was our acting
director he used to tick off all those
all those threats to our national
security uh when we travel together in
war zones and then he'd tell our young
officers that the silver lining and all
those dark clouds is that there was an
important job for all of us to do
on the front lines protecting our nation
detecting all those threats to our
national security so we could preempt
them before they're visited on our
shores that's an issue with this strike
and air bill is the extent to which we
could have collected intelligence on the
strike before it happened very hard to
do uh and especially if that strike
happened from iran as opposed to iran
using its proxy militias in country yeah
then i want to get your reaction to
what's happening in ukraine uh this this
week we found out that the president and
the national security council didn't
think it was a good idea to uh give the
ukrainians those jets they said that
putin would see it as provocative that
it would escalate the tension there
where are they getting that information
from is it are out assets that are on
the ground that are that are providing
uh the nsa that information
so it could be coming from just direct
line of of contact between our
department of defense uh and their
russian counterparts that's
uh official channels and it's happening
it's to deconflict uh it's been going on
for a long time it could be that
uh i would expect it's more likely that
than clandestine reporting but it also
could be clandestine reporting at the
end of the day at least in my view if
we're given the ukrainian stingers and
javelins giving them fighter aircraft is
kind of a distinction without a
difference either way they're using that
equipment
to target lethally to target russian uh
tanks and and their soldiers and uh
right now ukraine is in an
extraordinarily perilous situation
and i think one of the things for this
administration you know looking back the
question we'll have to ask is did we do
enough to deter the invasion in the
first place well the answer to that is
no we ran kind of a live twitter feed of
declassified cia intelligence reporting
on on an imminent invasion but we didn't
help ukraine prepare for it we didn't
help make it clear to russia would be uh
involved spilling an inordinate amount
of their blood and treasure so they went
ahead and did it and and you know i
think it's just got to weigh on the
conscience of our elected officials
especially president biden what we don't
do to help ukraine um that that's uh
that's a very significant i think issue
i'd have a hard time putting my head to
the pillow at night frankly without
doing giving the
ukrainians the mig fighter aircraft that
they need so much yeah
dan hoffman the former cia station chief
in moscow amanda knows his stuff dan
thanks so much for joining us on cross
country tonight hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else